bienvenue à la facture vous avez une
auto vous devriez ressortir votre
contrat pour voir si des frais ont été
ajoutés au prix quand vous avez annoncé
parce que c'est illégal mais comme vous
allez le voir certains vendeurs sont
très convaincants et même créatifs
j'ai trouvé cette ouverture là qui était
vraiment un prix plus raisonnable avec
le marché présentement c'est comme
impossible de trouver un prix abordable
mars 2022 leur Anne polliotte est
impliquée dans un accident de la route
une semi-remorque entre en collision
avec sa voiture
[Applaudissements]
elle sentir indemne mais son auto est
une perte totale elle doit rapidement en
trouver une autre sur une voiture à un
bon prix parce que je suis étudiant mais
il y en a pas il y en a plus sa mère
repère une messe des rouges 2015 chez
young des chersbrooke annoncé à
12487 dollars elle fait un dépôt par
téléphone pour réserver la voiture elle
précise que sa fille perra content parce
que pour moi c'est important
ce n'est qu'une fois chez le
concessionnaire alors que sa fille et
c'est la voiture qu'elle apprend qu'il y
aura des frais de 1500$ de plus si elle
paie content vous avez bien entendu
1500$ pour un véhicule annoncé sur
internet à
12487 dollars le but inciter le rang à
contracter un prêt on vous demande de
financer pour obtenir la ristourne la
banque
les banques offrent des ristournes aux
concessionnaires lorsque la voiture est
financée des ristournes qui peuvent
atteindre plusieurs centaines de dollars
voir jusqu'à 1500 dollars par voiture
vendu le vendeur de Hyundai Sherbrooke
propose même à la jeune femme un
stratagème étonnant contracté un prêt et
le rembourser en 6 mois pour éviter les
intérêts puis m'explique cela mais ça
sur un beau plateau d'or
moi si tu fais financer je vais avoir
une ristourne c'est juste 6 mois ça va
être facile à faire ça te coûtera pas
une scène de plus finalement tout le
monde est en rien moi j'ai mon argent
toi ça coûte pas plus cher donc moi je
connais pourquoi je refuserais
ça vous coûte rien
mais pour nous assez payant on n'aurait
pas un garage d'un point 6 millions si
on nous a pas de stratégie telles que
c'est celle-ci
puis moi c'est ce qui m'a dit
uber la montagne est conseillé juridique
à l'association pour la protection des
automobilistes tout à fait inacceptable
non pas le droit on peut on décide ou
qu'on veut financer avec eux avec notre
banc ou même payer content si on désire
le prix qui est affiché c'est le prix de
vente on peut pas rajouter des frais la
loi est pourtant claire un commerçant ne
peut exiger un prix supérieur à celui
qui est annoncé
young des Sherbrooke ne serait pas le
seul concessionnaire à exiger des frais
supplémentaires pour un achat comptant
des sources nous confient qu'il s'agit
d'une pratique courante dans l'industrie
automobile cette personne qui a déjà
travaillé chez différents
concessionnaires acceptent de témoigner
devant la caméra mais à visage
couvertures
le prix affiché est-ce que déjà le
concessionnaire rentre dans son argent
avec le prix affiché
Lorraine ne sait pas qu'elle est sur le
point de tomber dans un piège son mari
est comme non
mon côté je suis comme on trouve pas de
voiture ça coûte toujours trop cher on
s'en fout du confit de valeur on règle
ça plus tard moi j'achète la voiture non
non je sais que la pratique est
inacceptable c'est une violation peut
réduire en ce moment c'est scandaleux
dans cet échange enregistré par Laurent
lors de la transaction on entend le
vendeur dire qu'il a les mains liés que
la commande vient d'en haut et
complètement frauduleux
est-ce que justement cette histoire va
dans les poches du vendeur
et puis c'est je voudrais
d'ajouter des frais parce qu'on paye
content c'est illégal tout le monde le
sait aussi
tout le monde
des Sherbrooke a refusé notre demande
d'entrevue les au téléphone le
propriétaire ni avoir exigé des frais de
1500$ à sa cliente on est ici à la
madame parce qu'à payer content qu'on
lui chargeait 1500 pièces de plus c'est
complètement faux j'allais vérifier là
on a une feuille de vite avec un prix on
peut pas dire on char routier en 15
c'est complètement illégal justement
parlons de la feuille de vitre comme on
peut le voir ici le prix de la voiture
n'est pas le même que le prix annoncé
sur internet il a bondit en considérant
en les taxes exactement 1500 dollars
leur un SMS ont tout de même décidé
d'acheter la voiture et de débourser les
1500 dollars réclamés elles envisagent
maintenant de poursuivre Hyundai
Sherbrooke de par moi ma conscience j'ai
dit à Laurent on va acheter le véhicule
ensemble on va faire la démarche
ensemble
va apprendre à te faire respecter
partout tu vas aller on va être pas mal
plus fier de faire ce qu'on fait là puis
parce que c'est la satisfaction qu'on
veut retirer de tout de suite
avec la pénurie de voiture actuelle
certains concessionnaires se permettent
dans l'imposer des frais légaux et vous
allez voir des frais de toutes sortes à
tel point que certains disent maintenant
que l'Office de la protection du
consommateur devrait intervenir de façon
beaucoup plus musclée pour faire
respecter la loi
voilà fini sans lire 2018 voiture
électrique oui c'est le principal
argument pour laquelle j'ai acheté une
voiture vos prix d'essence ça coûte pas
cher qui est la conduite est excellente
moi j'adore la continuer
Vanessa Gervais à elle aussi toute une
surprise quand elle achète sa ni sans
livre 2018 en octobre dernier je sais
pas qui est venu à la prairie non
seulement elle est comme d'une pénalité
et de 500$ parce qu'elle est content
mais ce n'est pas tout
il me dit aussi que je devais payer 395
dollars pour un forfait et on dit que
tous les véhicules quand on les achetait
ça venait avec un forfait qu'on était
obligé de payer après cette conversation
que son conjoint enregistre lors de la
transaction on y entend David karakov le
directeur général de Parc Avenue la
prairie bon forfaits
que vous vendez
étonnamment ce forfait à 395 dollars
inclus un changement d'huile changement
d'huile pour une voiture électrique ben
moi je pense que c'est une manière de
faire plus d'argent sur le dos des
consommateurs puis nous on est obligé de
payer si on veut la voiture sinon ils
vont la vendre à quelqu'un d'autre or
non seulement un commerçant ne peut
exiger un prix supérieur au prix annoncé
mais tout ajout de produits ou de
services doit être à la demande du
consommateur c'est une vraie épidémie
c'est une culture institutionnaliser la
PA dénonce depuis des années ce qu'ils
appellent les faux frais d'ouverture de
dossiers frais administratif trousse de
départ frais de transport la liste est
longue la PA affirme recevoir de
nombreuses plaintes chaque année c'est
des millions de dollars qui sont allés
chercher dans les poches légalement des
consommateurs
selon une enquête de l'Office de la
protection du consommateur réalisé en
2018 47% des 175 commerçants ayant fait
l'objet d'une vérification aurait
facturé des frais illégalement c'est
presque un commerçant sur deux mais pour
ce qui est donc des frais qu'on impose
supplémentaire c'est très répandu dans
l'industrie
puis ça ça gonfler selon nos sources
cette pratique pourrait rapporter des
centaines de milliers de dollars par
année au concessionnaire combien en
moyenne par voiture vendue on va
chercher en frais additionnel en bonus
là si on veut
Vanessa Gervais a flairé le piège et
elle ne veut pas perdre la Nissan Leaf
elle décide de débourser les frais
supplémentaires exigées je me fais avoir
dans le fond je sais que je fais des
frais qui sont pas fâchés nulle part
donc je me fais avoir
le groupe Park Avenue a refusé notre
demande d'entrevue parce que cette
affaire est devant les tribunaux les
nous pressent l'effet que vous soulevez
remonte après d'un an et plusieurs
changements ont été apportés à nos
processus
Vanessa Gervais est à la tête d'une des
quatre actions collectives intensées
contre quelques 200 concessionnaires
automobiles au Québec des recours
pilotés par Maître Jimmy Lambert
toujours en attente d'approbation c'est
comme ouvrir une boîte de Pandore
lorsqu'on a déposé ce raccord collectif
là jamais j'aurais pensé que ça arrête
paralysé le bureau à ce point-là chaque
jour on reçoit des dénonciations reçoit
des inscriptions on en reçoit de la
nouvelle preuve selon maître Lambert
bien des consommateurs se sentent prises
au piège donc un choix de signer
document qui payent un frais
supplémentaire ou finalement de ne pas
avoir la voiture au début des dépôts des
raccords
changer les choses et maintenant je
dans ce domaine là la corporation des
concessionnaires automobiles du Québec
n'est pas du même avis que Maître
Lambert
des choses et qui dit hors de tout doux
voici des concessionnaires ont
transgressé la Loi ça ça sera un jeu qui
va devoir le faire je vous réitère que
l'industrie de l'automobile c'est 45000
employés c'est 900 concessionnaires au
Québec ici on a 80 ou 10 transactions
qui sont questionnaires ou qu'on doit
vérifier mais on va le faire maintenant
est-ce que on est devant une pratique
qui englobe l'ensemble des
concessionnaires je ne le crois pas nous
décidons de faire nos propres
vérifications chez différents
concessionnaires visés par les recours
nous visitons 10 concessionnaires muni
de caméras cachées dans une simple
démarche de magazine âge sans aller
jusqu'à acheter la voiture on constate
que chez trois d'entre eux des frais
supérieures au prix affiché sont exigés
comme ici chez ottomax à
Saint-Jean-sur-Richelieu notre
collaborateur demande au vendeur le prix
final de ce Highlander sur une
estimation rédigée à la main un moitié
son attention les frais c'est quoi
c'est optionnel
programme d'esthétique optionnel 386
dollars
là je l'ai inclus dans le paiement mais
vous êtes obligé de le vendre rappelons
que
tout propice ne peut être ajouté car la
demande du client ici notre
collaborateur n'a rien demandé le
propriétaire de Thomas c'est lui José
Santos il refuse de venir s'expliquer à
la caméra et voici ce qui nous exprime
lors d'une conversation téléphonique
clairement programme d'esthétique de
véhicule
optionnel c'est marqué optionnel puis on
demande verdalement est-ce que vous
voulez avoir le programme d'esthétique à
automatiquement
à 100%
pourtant lors de notre visite ce n'est
que lorsque notre collaborateur pose des
questions qui la prend qu'il s'agit
d'une option un autre concessionnaire
dans la région de Québec cette fois mais
tout en oeuvre pour imposer le
financement
il refuse de vendre content parce qu'ils
ont pas leur estime de financement
autrefois pas ce vendeur à l'intention
d'exiger des frais de 123 dollars en
lien avec le rdpm le registre des droits
personnels est réel mobilier 123 c'est
quoi c'est
pour faire un prêt il y a toujours un
montage
selon le fils de la protection du
consommateur les frais de RDPRM doivent
aussi être inclus dans le prix annoncé
Beauport Nissan n'a jamais donné suite à
nos demandes d'entrevue
depuis son enquête de vérification
l'Office de la protection du
consommateur a émis plus de 80 avis de
rappel et d'infraction au
concessionnaires neuf ont été déclarés
coupables et ont écopé d'amandes allant
de 1500 à 26000 dollars pour avoir exigé
un prix supérieur au prix annoncé
n’empêche certains continuent d'exiger
des frais additionnels comme le démontre
notre visite chez saint Jérôme Chrysler
c'est Jérôme a pourtant appelé
découpable en décembre 2020 et a été
condamné à payer 12000 dollars d'amende
ce concessionnaire a aussi décliné notre
demande d'entrevue parce qu'il est visé
par une action collective mais nous
écrit nous contestons la prétention à
l'effet que nous chargeons un prix
supérieur à celui annoncé
continuez à enfreindre la loi et plus
payant
la respecter
[Musique]
si il y a des gens qui font des
transactions illégales c'est évident
qu'on endose pas une transaction
illégale et ici elle est connue c'est ce
et certain que le propriétaire quelle
concessionnaire va prendre évidemment
les actions pour la corriger rapidement
on croit que l'Office de protection du
consommateur le chaper sur ce dossier là
l'Office devrait intervenir et suspendre
les permis carrément c'est ce qu'on
demande c'est la seule solution que l'on
croit assez solide pour faire réfléchir
les commerçants ce qui me fâche le plus
c'est de voir que l'OPC
n'ont pas mis leur culotte pourtant la
présidente de l'Office de la protection
du consommateur a le pouvoir de
suspendre ou d'annuler le permis d'un
commerçant nous avons demandé à
Marie-Claude Champoux devenir expliqué
la position de l'Office à la caméra
malgré notre insistance elle délègue de
porte-parole de l'OPC Charles Tanguay
mais la présidente quand même le pouvoir
de retirer les permis donc pourquoi pas
le faire immédiatement pour envoyer un
message clair il y en aura probablement
des cas de retraite permis en tout cas
il y a eu des menaces de retraite permis
et ça semble effectivement fonctionner
dans ce cas là il y a des gens qui vous
reprochent de manquer de mordant
à l'office
pourtant nous avons l'impression dans le
dossier automobile d'avoir montré les
dents d'avoir fait beaucoup d'efforts
pour à la hauteur je crois de l'ampleur
du problème et
les prochains mois vont le dire si la
situation ne se corrige pas le fils va
montrer des dents encore plus encore
plus acérées je vous dirais d'aller
jusqu'à retirer le permis ça aurait quoi
comme
impacts
en attendant des mesures plus musclées
Vanessa Gervais espère que son action
collective sera autorisée et qu'elle
fera bouger les choses je sais que j'ai
été obligé de payer ça alors qu'il s'en
avait pas besoin puis je suis pas la
seule qui fait avoir il y en a beaucoup
d'autres donc on veut que ça reste
[Musique]
si vous découvrez que vous avez payé des
frais légaux demandez d'abord à votre
concessionnaire de vous les rembourser
s'il refuse vous pouvez porter plainte à
l'Office de la protection du
consommateur et vous adresser au
tribunaux je vous rappelle que les
quatre actions collectives en sont au
stade de l'autorisation mais si vous
voulez en savoir plus notamment si votre
concessionnaire en fait partie
rendez-vous sur notre site internet